estas elecciones a la comunidad de
madrid se han erigido en dos bloques
antagónicos los candidatos de la
izquierda pablo iglesias absolutamente
mónica garcía y ángel gabilondo el
presidente del lado de la derecha
edmundo oval y la actual presidenta
isabel díaz ayuso así como la candidata
de extrema derecha rocío monasterio una
polarización que no ha sido del gusto de
todos los votantes en el ambiente
enrarecido encrespado por unos por otros
no hay ninguno que diga voy a centrarme
lo que me tengo que centrar no voy a
ponerme a discutir con él en frente voy
a hablar de mi programa y no voy a
insultar no voy a entrar en esta
dinámica sin embargo son muchos los
votantes que ven en el bloque rival una
gran amenaza a sus intereses desde la
izquierda se teme que 10 ayuso pacte un
gobierno con la otra derecha y se
critica la privatización de la sanidad
pública y la gestión de la pandemia
hombre por el lado de la hostelería todo
el mundo tiene derecho a comer lo que
pasa que la sanidad y hasta la salud en
lo primero
todo lo que sí que tenían que hacer es
más ayudas
cerrar la hostelería cerrar todo lo que
tengan que cerrar y más ayudas lo cierto
es que madrid ha llegado a ser la región
de europa más afectada por el cob y 19
pero la actual presidenta opone es un
modelo de restricciones las alzas del
gobierno central y otras regiones lo
está haciendo bien con este tema un poco
de pues abierto a los bares un poco más
de libertad y tal porque si no
estaríamos todos en un caos como por
ejemplo ha pasado en bilbao como ha
pasado en otros muchos sitios la franca
ha sido un desastre pero el bloque de
izquierdas podría sumar los escaños
suficientes para gobernar en coalición
para lo que han buscado a la
movilización de los barrios obreros sin
ellos díaz ayuso gobernará hasta el
final de la legislatura en 2023